foreign
these days we've gotten spoiled by
amazing animation from the decade-long
history of modern anime to expect a show
or two exhibiting sargoga every season
but anime didn't exactly look this good
before it hasn't always been like this
still there are some shows from the past
decade or two that have exceeded
expectation and wowed us with
spectacular editing animation or simply
composition for me these are some of the
standouts i'm certain you'll be able to
call some titles as early as now but who
knows there could be some surprises
lying in wait
starting off we have beyond the boundary
not what you expected huh beyond the
boundary is probably not in everyone's
expectations when talking about visually
stunning action anime and it's easy to
see why it had a niche fan base before
when it was airing but now it's been
almost a decade since airing no one
really remembers the show much it's not
the first name to come up with when you
go through your castle of cure any shows
and it's a shame one of kyoani's first
foray into full-on supernatural action
is an experiment gone right in my
opinion fluid action sequences and a
perfect atmosphere for this dark action
series helped boy this show that
unfortunately had good but not
spectacular reception it's not shinkai
or anything but for its time beyond the
boundary also had some of my favorite
sceneries and visuals out of anything
airing in that season we can also thank
youni's visual directing for that one i
think it's easily one of the studio's
strongest points
at number nine we have kay
for those who were around in the early
2010s likely in uk for one thing the
filters before no game no life made it
cool k was known as the charismatic show
that had the unique tint being plastered
on the screen all the time i also meant
that it's known for one thing it's
stunning action sequences make no
mistake k is a show that carries with it
a lot of cool rebel energy if you get
what i mean and that strong point gets
accentuated even more with its art and
animation overall k just looks simply
beautiful the visuals vividly capture
the atmosphere of the bustling city
filled with skyscrapers and the fights
are as the video's title suggests
visually stunning it gets especially
great when the people start soaring and
the camera angles capture the impact of
each object's motions k as well as the
succeeding season in the movie is a
series that takes you on a literal
thrill ride and while the screen filters
can be a bit hit or miss the animation
is definitely a thing to lord
in eighth place sword art online
in a contrast of the first entries now
this is a show that needs no
introduction with the series still going
relatively strong for its decade long
run pretty much everything that can be
said about sao has been said somewhere
on the internet no matter what your
opinions on the franchise as a whole are
however one thing cannot be denied in
terms of production values sao is king
short there's the meme kirito shot and
other hiccups but take it as a whole sao
is a show that undeniably looks good a1
pictures themselves don't have the most
stellar reputations but if you want a
show for them to demonstrate their skill
you can just point to what's become
their flagship title by the time the
series reached the war of underworld arc
there was sakuga almost every other
episode coming at us with some of the
most extravagant lights and fireworks
the franchise has ever seen though over
100 episodes two movies and counting and
all the extra anime content one thing
has remained consistent with sao and
that is it's excellent art and animation
quality
[Music]
next up we have gekkai sensen in seventh
place
[Music]
nowadays it seems that people know gekko
sensing more for its ending theme you
know the first season's very popular
ending sequence that has been parodied
quite often that fact gives me mixed
feelings because while i love how the
show's getting some love moving past the
ending sequence i legitimately enjoyed
this supernatural foray into hell
salem's lot with the ever trusty
leonardo watch on our side the episodic
nature of most of the episodes may not
be a lot for people but for those who
just wanted their dose of urban fantasy
action you'll be in for hell of a treat
studio bones really went all out for
this decently niche title to produce
what i believe is one of the best
animated action series in 2015. the
great art and animation helps support
the character writing which many
appraised and what you get is a title
that unexpectedly exceeded all
expectations that i had it's also got
another season which likewise delivered
the same goodness so the fun doesn't end
in just 12 episodes
we proceed to movieland with garden of
sinners at 6.
ah one of the many lesser-known nasu
titles garden of sinners is mostly known
for its very intricate storytelling the
mysterious aura that it carries and to a
lesser extent the breathtaking visuals
perhaps it's because people expect great
visuals from a theatrical production but
the garden of sinners movies go beyond
those expectations and shatter them over
the course of seven movies the mid to
late 2000s is still quite early in their
history but ufo table already started
showing glimpses of the future with how
the garden of sinners movie was animated
very fluid and well choreographed action
sequences get coupled with those
melancholic backdrops and detailed
environments create the mysterious air
the movie series has most of the time
the character designs are also a thing
of beauty and looking at garden of
sinners overall i guess it's a prelude
of things to come for ufo table
now before we continue i'd like to
mention that we finally have a discord
server so check the link in the
description after you finish the video
and join the community for giveaways
events anime discussion and other fun
stuff now let's continue with the video
at number five we take a look at the
newest kid on the block jujutsu kaizen
it's finally time to talk about the cool
kid of the 2020s jiu jitsu kaizen to say
the jiu jitsu kaizen's best point is the
animation i feel would be doing the
anime a very minor disservice when it
comes to the world of battle shonen i
personally feel that jiu jitsu kaizen is
more than the sparks and flashes it's
got some creative usage of its cast goes
slightly past norms while keeping in
line with the established tropes of the
genre and introduces us to some really
nice fight setups but i can't blame you
if the first thing that strikes out to
you for jiu jitsu kaizen is its
animation i mean sakuraga is just
everywhere injured to kaizen we can talk
about the hanami fight or half the
things gojo does or fushiguro's glorious
moment at the tail end of the series
almost every episode there's something
in the visual spectacle that is
jiu-jitsu kaizen that makes people's
jaws drop jiu-jitsu kaizen is the newest
addition to the ever-growing library of
anime titans to take the world by storm
and made the best entrance that anyone
could hope for
right after jiu jitsu kaizen is demon
slayer
to no one's surprise demon slayer is on
this list and yes i intentionally placed
it next to jiu jitsu kaizen because in a
more meta sense the two shows feel like
successes to each other given their
similar trajectories and success
settings changed characters change but
the whole premise of a team of
specialists fighting supernatural and
demonic beings lives on for demon slayer
everyone can talk about rui but have you
seen what ufo table did with the movie
how about the time zinitsu showed off
how badass he can be heck even in the
currently airing red light district arc
there's no shortage of demon slayer just
being
visually stunning vivid backgrounds a
bright art style that captures the vigor
of the era and spectacular
post-processing effects that enhance
every moment they're in it's rare for it
to happen but demon slay is a title that
manages to surpass its source material
thanks to these extravagant visuals it's
a no-brainer that demon slayers on here
and if you've been in the anime
community for the past year or so you
wouldn't have needed to hear that from
me
we open our top three with mushoku
tensei
of course the granddaddy of isakai isn't
gonna disappoint i don't blame you if
you had your doubts however after all
given how saturated isakai is these days
we have a lot of these low budget filler
works it would be a crime against
humanity if the anime gods dare saddle
mushoku tensei with that treatment right
all those fears were put to the test
when the first episodes dropped and the
momentum just kept going mushoku tensei
is a title with a very lush and vibrant
setting and much of the world building
and the feeling of discovering a whole
new world were brought to life thanks to
the studio's skill in background design
and fight animation mushoku tensei
boasts a lot of fights that really give
off that much needed impact a fight has
to have thanks to the animation team not
every show gets the honour of having a
studio made solely for adapting it you
know that's how we know these guys are
serious about mushoku tensei and it's up
to us to enjoy the fruits of the team's
labor controversies and all this is by
far one of the most well-made isakai out
there
second place is mob psycho 100
again i don't think that i need to tell
you anything about the amazing visuals
of mob psycho 100 an amazing series in
its own right people all over the world
have loved mob psycho for its
interesting characters engaging plot and
of course the godly animation and fight
sequences in fact you could be around
back when people were up in arms because
the title didn't win best animation in
one crunchyroll award or something but
that's besides the point what i'm here
to highlight is the cinematic aesthetics
that mob psycho has it looks deceptively
simplistic they are but when you start
seeing the fight sequences how the
powers get presented and how everything
just moves and reacts according to the
events you're seeing on screen just
prepare to be blown away art and
animation is not mob psycho's strongest
suit for me but it sure is the one that
strikes out among its peers mob psycho
100 is an adaptation that showcases the
power of an adaptation just like demon
slayer it's a title that shows how being
able to see and hear things brings you a
way better experience than just reading
something
the most visually stunning action anime
for me is none other than ufo table's
fate
[Music]
fate stay night didn't have the most
glorious art it's not that dean's day
night is absolutely awful but it's a
show that didn't do too much to bring
the fake franchise to the mainstream
back in the mid 2000s you'd be laughed
at if you thought that this little vian
adaptation would soon turn into a money
printer in the world of mobile games and
anime fate struck gold when ufo table
got handed the reigns to adapt both fate
zero and unlimited blade works and it
just snowballed from there finally fate
had an adaptation done right and it
couldn't have found a better studio to
do it one of the best modern vn
adaptations the two anime continued the
series momentum and before you know it
we have a multi-billion dollar franchise
on our hands from the very smooth fight
animation to the amazing presentation
that really drove home how overwhelming
the noble phantasms are ufo tables fate
has everything you'd want from an action
anime if we're talking about visual
presentation and that's not even getting
to the heavens field movies if you're
looking for a long franchise that can
fill you with hours of exciting fights
and visual spectacles ufo tables fate is
here for you and don't worry about the
notorious watch order you can just go
zero then ubw or heaven's field
[Music]
so is ufo tables fate your pick for most
visually stunning action anime why or
why not tell me in the comment section i
hope you had a great time watching this
video i'd appreciate it if you drop a
like and check out what the rest of the
channel has to offer oh and if you're up
for it too you can also try supporting
me through memberships and my patreon
both which will be in the description
box you can also join my discord for
giveaways and anime discussions thank
you for watching and i hope you have a
great day see you next time